HE'LL CENTRE A LINE BETWEENGHT .
WRISTER, DEFLECTED,
SCORES!
AND NO TIME WASTED AT ALL.
HE IS FIRING THAT ON
BRINGS A GREAT OFFFFE, HE CUTS
SHOOTS, SPACE, R
LETS COUTURE GO AND HE PULLS
BURNS RETREATS TO HIS OWN ZONE.
3-NOTHING DEFICIT.
>> Dave: NO QUESTION ABOUT IT.
DAHLEN.
ANOTHER ICING CALL AS DAVID
SAVARD BACK TO TOUCH THE IN, DR
OF GOOD PLAYS BY   ON KARLSSON
FROM DI DAVID SAVARD'S
SKATE IN FRONT OF THE NET.
JAKE ALLEN ROLLS H HME.
AS THE SAN JOSE SHARKS, GAME O O
SAVARD WRIST SHOT.
HIGH REBOUND IN TIGHT AND
THAT SPEED AND, YEAH, DVORAK
THAT CLOSE TO GETTING O
ULF DAHLEN --
GOING TO DRIVE IF IN BY ALLEN.
COUTURE.KARLSSON TO HIS RIGHT F
IN 61 GAMES AS ASTER JABS
FOR WEATHERBY
ADVANTAGE.MSELVES OUT OF
HERE'S SUZUKI.
HE WAS STILL TRYING TO GET
ACCLIMATIZEDDEMAN, AND
OFF
SIDE.
>> Dave: JOEL ARMIA FRUSTRATED
.
SUZUKI...
TRYING TO COLLECT THE PUCK.
S
TWO ON TWO.
A NICE LITTLE PASS BUT A S THE
OUT.
KARTEP TOWARDS
THE MIDDLE AND
LEHKONEN ON THE MOVE FOR MRN.